women the most loyal with a whole
divestment movement
divestment because they and that's
actually a good point
um there's a movement pretty much on
social media called divesters and
they're basically black women that are
like we're done with black men black men
are trash we're gonna go and get us some
you know non-black men let's open our
options we don't need black men they're
dogs they're trash they're weak they're
lazy they're broke that like they're not
they're not just doing it but they have
to trash black men on the way out do you
understand like we've a lot of vile
Venom like do you know what I'm saying
so what do you think about that have you
like ever come across any women that are
that pertain to that kind of way of
thinking no there's a lot of trash by
the way it is trash but there's a lot of
men that kind of do that so why are you
guys surprised when a woman does it oh
I'm not surprised in general like why is
everyone surprised when a woman when a
woman group does it when but it
consistently happened
the one thing I will say I'm again I'm
going to tell you get the likes up on
the video I'm going to say some real ish
right now yeah
um the the reality of that and why it's
kind of like I don't think black guys
really find it serious with this whole
divestment thing because just like the
young lady said and she was a black
woman she said it herself black women
unfortunately unfairly or however you
want to look at it are not seen as the
standard of beauty they're not so to
have a movement where you're trying to
gravitate to men who have deliberately
made sure you're not the standard of
beauty and try to use them as a weapon
or some kind of oh yeah look they want
us and you don't want us it's kind of
ridiculous at the end of the day
do you get what I'm saying like they
they have reinforced this idea all these
stereotypes that we're talking about
that black women have have been
reinforced by a non-black non-black uh
media
[Music]
black media has propped up the blonde
blue eyes woman as the standard of
beauty so like to come back and then say
oh yeah no no no no no no we can get men
outside like really can you really know
that beauty standard though is that just
a curse of living in the west yeah I
think there'll be standards across the
world it's across the world bro I don't
know how many how many African people
countries whatever how many people do in
our background that are still bleaching
their skin and you know it is it is it
is
like bro there's bleaching their skin in
the Caribbean islands they're bleaching
the skin in African continent that says
it all we're not even talking about UK
and USA yeah
come on bro
yeah kind of but I don't know like it's
a tough one but you have to yeah it is
no I get it it that happens but I'm not
gonna lie you you go to Africa and I'm
speaking specifically living with
angolans like dangling black black woman
is beautiful and actually she's quite
praise go to South Africa as well like a
lot of the the
um because obviously they still say like
they still have a race issues but a lot
of like adverts and a lot of these
things actually feature very beautiful
black women the I think obviously when
you are in the west and you're out of
your home you are going to stand out
like a sofa and it's not always going to
be in a good way go back home go to your
country of origin or whatever just
experience it for one week and you'll
see how your life will change I agree I
think I think a lot of times when um
when I've heard black women complain and
say oh yeah all these black guys they
don't want us they don't like black
women blah blah blah I'm like bro okay
maybe you should go to a black country
then if you're if you if you really do
want to be of a black man you can if you
really want to you get what I'm saying
but like and then and then it comes to
dating requirements oh are you only
trying to go off the guys that are over
six foot are you trying to only go off
the guys that are making six figures are
you only because then you're kind of
narrowing down your market and your
potential can I say something so
basically like about back to the beauty
standards like a lot of white women are
now adopting black women features like
the big lips the big bum the big like
The Hourglass shape so how can we say
that the back off how can we say their
Instagram workouts bro every time every
time I have to train somebody aha I win
a big but like come on bro like the
whole body yeah you get me but anyway go
on yeah so how can we say that the the
the beauty standard is still blonde
white blue eyes because all these white
women are adopting these ethnic women
like features yeah yeah but that's sorry
yeah but that's now and that's only
through social social media like if
we're talking about Western being
standards if we're talking about Western
beauty standards that's happened through
colonization it's happened through us
coming here because we we can't have a
life now in our country when we were
fine before anybody walks in like these
are things that have been so debruted
for centuries that have like been
drilled into people's minds like
people's Bloodlines have been diluted
because the white man has come into your
land and done what he's done and on top
of that like it's just crazy like I
think yes now we know we're seeing but
all of this stuff is all celebrity stuff
it's not common people stuff like common
people stuff is as real trauma it's real
like generational pain that your your
bloodline has gone through that you
might be able to connect with and
understand all this you know going to
get lipo and bbo and you need to want to
make your lips bigger and at the end of
the day there's black women that are
doing bbos so so then it kind of defeats
the whole thing
but it's not about the body type
necessarily that we're discussing is
this no but you're no no because Iman
was talking about
um non-black women trying to basically
emulate black women but then if black
women are going to do bbls who are they
emulating no it is they just want they
just emulating yeah emulating myself
that's so mad you are Taps that's it let
me move on all right we got Daniel for
the Super Chat good show King as always
big up the panel big up some of you my
brother appreciate that hey bigger we
got to recall unfortunately many women
in our community like Fox
who objects to that we like the bad boy
bad boy is different from the thug
that's and I think that's women period
yeah I was going to say that that's just
gonna say that I've got a rebuttal but
carry on go on say it say it it's gone I
think that's women in general is not
just black woman and I think also like
age range like you're not gonna say
you're not gonna ask a 40 year old woman
if she likes a thug by a 20 year old
wood yes yeah the bad boy like
references
listen every woman wants a bad boy but
some women they want they want the
neurosurgeon who who's on point he could
also be the bad boy yeah he's a bad boy
they want Top Gun they want the they
want the fourth officer he's killing
what they want the Navy SEAL kill it
they're killing people they're shooting
people so every woman wants a bad boy
but they're different so our bad boys
are different than the other ones yeah
yeah I think I think it's more they just
want an alpha male yeah we want like a
protector if you're the main doctor on
the ward like right you're not a bad boy
but you're the alpha like all the women
in that all the nurses but if we if we
and and if but the thing is if we can
compare it by Community to communities
of women by communities of women yeah
their perception has in our community
especially in the west maybe not so much
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible